2020 une année compliquée pour le marché
automobile en france les ventes de
voitures pour particuliers ont chuté de
25 5% en un an
c'est la plus grosse baisse recensés sur
les 40 dernières années
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée la
crise financière de 2008 n'avait
engendré qu'une baisse de 13 88% dans ce
secteur le groupe renault comme le
groupe psa enregistre une chute de 25,1
et 24 9%
une crise qui ne touche donc pas un
producteur français plus qu'un autre
parmi les groupes étrangers qui vendent
en france c'est le groupe fiat chrysler
qui regroupe notamment alfa romeo et
jeep et fiat qui a le plus souffert avec
plus de 40 % de pertes
pour rappel une fusion a été signé entre
le groupe italo américain et psa le 4
janvier dernier donnant le nom de ce thé
lantiss le groupe qui devait ainsi
prendre la quatrième place mondiale au
classement des constructeurs de
l'automobile se retrouvera après le
crise probablement à la 6e position au
final seuls les entités hyundai et
toyota-lexus en sorte avec un peu moins
de 15% de baisse sur le chiffre
d'affaires du marché français si l'on
devait retenir autre chose de cette
année c'est bien l'augmentation
significative des ventes de voitures
hybrides et électriques
face à la crise l'état a procédé à
l'augmentation du bonus écologique pour
booster les ventes
ce sont environ 149 mille
immatriculations qui ont été créés pour
des voitures de ce type contre seulement
60 milles en 2019
une croissance qui devrait se poursuivre
cette année également puisque le bonus
écologique pour l'achat de voitures en
2021 pour et à lui jusqu'à 7000 euros
plus globalement en 2021 l'observatoire
cetelem prévoit une croissance du marché
de l'automobile de 19% en france les
intentions des français d'acheter une
voiture n'aurait pas changé malgré la
crise qu'il osera seulement contraints à
pousser leurs projets d'acquisition d'un
véhicule à plus tard